I am in love I talk about it all the
time I talk to my friends about it I
talk to my roommates about it I share
way too many details of strangers I show
them weird pictures I'm practically
shouting it from the rooftops I'm
totally and utterly in love with things
and buy things I mean the clothes you're
wearing the chair you're sitting in the
pen you're holding I mean everything you
touch and everything you see because to
me things aren't just things today I
want to share my love of things i want
to share why I think things are so
important to me and to you because
things have impacts that are far greater
than what we think of when we just think
of things things created our past they
made us who we are today they're shaping
our every moment in the present and
they're creating the future and the
building of things the act of physically
creating things has the power to
transform lives I feel like I'm working
in Sanford's product realization lab
this is a place where you can build
pretty much anything you can imagine you
can find every tool you could ever dream
up and you can do things like 3d
printing laser cutting injection molding
silversmithing this fall I tried welding
for the first time and I was completely
hooked so while many of my business
school classmates were spending their
time pursuing high-tech endeavors really
taking advantage of our location in
Silicon Valley at the GSB I spent night
after night doing something much more
low-tech dressed like this
so working in the product realization
lab has changed how I dress but more
than that it's changed how I look at the
world in many ways I was disconnected
from the things around me beings
magically appear on shelves and I bought
them took them home use them broke them
and they went back to the same stores
about new things that magically appeared
on the same shelves I was disconnected
from the materials from how they were
made and from what they meant for me but
when I'm welding or working in the
woodshop when I'm covered in sawdust or
steel shavings I think about these
things differently the more time I spend
building things the more I appreciate
them more I appreciate the world because
things aren't just things and things
have never been just things from the
first moment our distant ancestors chose
certain stones and pounded them with
other stones to create the first tools
these things have been influencing where
we live how we communicate who we talk
to and even our physical bodies research
indicates that the way the bones in our
hands are shaped today is a direct
result of the original tools we built so
we developed our opposable thumbs and
our metacarpal structure that has
strength and dexterity to reflect these
original tools and from this first
moment in time things have been creating
and defining societies cultures are
remembered by the things that they build
its things that create culture things
create fashion art architecture music
and technology things create the world
because things aren't just things and
today we're surrounded by so many things
that are impacting what we do how we
feel how we think and some are playing a
larger role in your experience right now
like your chair do you notice your chair
how does it feel is it the right height
is it the right amount of cushion is it
making you want to sit up straight or
kind of slouch
down how was that in turn affecting your
experience right now and how are all the
other things in this room impacting how
you feel right now and all of these
things were built by someone or
something somewhere the internet does a
great job of connecting us across the
world but these things they physically
connect us with the people who built
them on these desks were connected to
the people who extracted the oil to make
the laminate for the top to the steel
workers who extruded the steel tubing
for the legs the factory workers who
kept the production lines running the
crew on the ship who brought it to us
the interior designer in the architect
who chose this specific desk for the
specific room in this orientation
everything is a story of connections and
of people because things aren't just
things and this brings me to the future
the things we build help us grow in
advance and learn and evolve and just
like the things in our past and our
present create who we are today the
things in the present will in the things
in the future will influence where we go
and what we do it's hard to say exactly
how but what we do know is that we're
moving further and further from building
these things ourselves learning more and
more of our designing on screens
interacting in a virtual world we're
becoming disconnected from manufacturing
schools are dropping home in home
economics and shop classes and we're
losing the basic building skills that
generations before us had and there's so
many great things that happen in the
virtual world so much beautiful design
but today I want to ask you to not
forget about building in the physical
world because building things with your
hands has serious benefits it engages
your mind in a way that the virtual
world just cannot research shows that
when we move our hands to build things
our brains are flooded with dopamine and
serotonin these are two
neurotransmitters that are linked with
higher levels of these are linked with
lower depression and mood disorders and
when we move our hands rather than other
parts of our bodies we actually release
more dopamine and serotonin
there are other benefits that are less
measurable but still very real making
things engages both hemispheres of your
brain which can improve focus and
building things allows you to feel a
sense of usefulness in control in a
world that can often feel abstract and
out of control and if we do all of our
designing on screens and all of our
iterating and PowerPoint we run the risk
of losing this and we run the risk of
kids losing this too much time in front
of screens has been linked with obesity
irregular sleep and behavioral problems
in children on the other hand building
things has ties to higher student
engagement and graduation rates in
California students who took shop
classes graduated at higher rates they
performed better on high school exit
exams and they were more likely to
pursue a post-high school education the
National Science Foundation found that
students who studied engineering using
hands on building techniques learn more
than their peers who studied using books
and lectures and what other creative
programs such as art or cut from schools
these schools see increase of vandalism
in delinquency because building building
things allows kids to feel a sense of
control they learn how to try and fail
and then try again when glue won't hold
or a joint won't stick they learn how to
actually put a theory into practice and
they learn about persistence and
initiative which are two things that
studies show maybe more closely linked
to success than intelligence and they
get to come home from school and say I
made this I believe it is critical to
provide learning opportunities that are
not driven by a mouse or screen or an
imaginary world built from pixels I want
kids and us to see the world around us
to touch the world around us and to
create the world around us because
things aren't just things so the good
news is it's so close this world is
right at our fingertips maybe after
hearing me today you want to learn to
weld that is so exciting please come
with me come to the product realz
in lab or go to a tech shop or look
online for classes in your community and
you can start small too and still see
the effects of building you can write a
handwritten letter or make your own
jewelry or pottery or take a stab at
fixing that broken chair leg it's not
going to get any more broken and when
you sign your kids up for classes in
sports and music there might also be
programs that teach fashion design or
how to build robots so after today you
might not start welding you might miss
our building your own furniture or
making your own soap but I would invite
you to take a moment to look at the
things around you to touch the things
around you and to think about what they
mean for the world because I'm totally
in love with things because things
aren't just things